In this video which is part of the greater
project revolution we’re going to be talking
about the Mexican war of independence in the
early 19th century.
However before we start talking about the
Mexican war of independence or more accurately
the Wars of independence.
We have to understand the social, political,
economical and religious aspects that drove
the Mexican ideas of revolution in the first
place.
And for that we’ll have to look at the Viceroyalty
of New Spain.
Also known as the Colony of New Spain.
This colony was governed in all administrative
aspects by the Viceroy, who was appointed
by the Spanish monarch.
The Viceroy was supposed to govern a colony
which at its largest extended included Southern
Canada, Venezuela, the Philippines, Florida,
etc. the pure scale of this colony meant that
the Viceroy couldn’t really govern the entire
viceroyalty effectively and therefore most
of the administrative and judicial matters
fell to the local governmental bodies, the
largest of which where the audiencias.
There’s way more political organization
in New Spain then we have time to get in to
but some important things of note are that
the audiencias had to not only answer directly
to the viceroy but also the council and minister
of the indies.
However this was only in administrative matters
not judicial ones.
Plus the audiencias weren't even the only
governmental body, as there were smaller ones
called cabildo, intendencies, captaincies
general, etc.
Lastly what is important to understand, is
that even though this was the ViceRoyalty
of New Spain at its largest extent, the borders
often changed and the viceroy control in some
border regions was purely superficial.
This vast colony was governed from the former
aztec capital Tenochtitlan now renamed Mexico
City.
Mexico City was not only the administrative
heartland of New Spain but also the economical
and social one.
It was the largest city in the Western Hemisphere
in the 18th century and was connected from
the pacific by the port of Acapulco and the
Caribbean by the Port of Veracruz.
This trade network going across the heartland
of Mexico created drastic economic development
within the area which resulted in the fact
that by the 18th century, the lands between
Veracruz, Mexico City and Acapulco had over
half of the entire population of New Spain.
However this population of New Spain was very
heavily divided in to a casta system.
This system assigned social, economic, administrative
and other privileges to people depending on
their racial background.
Now this system in its purest form was very
simple but in practice it was anything but
simple.
It also changed drastically since the foundation
of new spain in 1521 until the early 19th
century.
With that said I am going to be presenting
the casta system as it existed in the late
18th century.
So the simple system went like this.
On top where the peninsulares, people born
in Spain or elsewhere in Europe.
This group had the largest social and economic
benefits and almost all high ranking administrative
and governmental jobs in the colony could
be held by only them.
Under Peninsulares were the Criollos, which
were people born to both Spanish or european
parents in the Americas.
Criollos mostly had the same benefits as Peninsulares
with the exception that they could only be
appointed to lower level governmental jobs.
Under the Criollos were mostly two classes.
The Indios or Amerindians and the Mestizos.
The Indios where people purely descended from
the native Indian population, and in fact
some amerindian communities where very strict
in the notion of pure blood Indios.
It is very hard to classify this group because
their social status was very heavily dependent
on the families background.
For example the Aztec nobility that existed
prior to the Spanish colonization got pretty
much assimilated into the Spanish nobility.
On top of that some Indios people became very
wealthy through mine or farm ownership and
those people enjoyed a very high standard
within the society.
With that said most of the indios people in
Mexico where poor peasants that were not allowed
to hold any administrative jobs other than
in specifically defined amerindian communities.
The Mestizos where people descended from one
Indios parent and one Spanish/European parent.
In the early colonial era this term was associated
with being a bastard as Mestizos where oftentimes
born out of wedlock however in the late 18th
century the term started to be much more widespread
and started to encompass more racial subdivisions
then just purely having one indios and one
european parent.
By the 19th century the word Mestizo started
to be used to describe any kind of a mixed
race person.
Mestizos as Indios are hard to classify as
depending on their wealth, family history,
and sometimes just purely skin color, they
could have benefits as high as of a Criollo.
Under Indios and Mestizos were Mulatos, which
were people of european and African descended,
and later also included people of Amerindian
and African descent.
These people where at the low end of the casta
system not having any real benefits and if
their mom was a slave they could also end
up being slaves.
Lastly where the Negros, people of pure African
decent.
These people were mostly slaves or descendants
of slaves brought to New Spain mainly during
the 17th century, when Spain ruled over Portugal
and its vast Portuguese slave trade.
However it is interesting to note that even
though legal by the late 18th century slave
ownership was almost non existent and the
population of Africans in mainland of New
Spain was no more than 0.2%.
This was mostly because by the end of the
18th century there was an abundance of cheap
labor, mainly from the growing mestizo class.
This combined with the fact that mainland
New Spain had mostly higher profit margin
jobs like the textile industry, the die industry,
mining, etc. meant that slavery was largely
obsolete.
The last important driving force in New Spain
was Catholicism.
The Spanish inquisition was in full force
back in Europe and that mentality got very
much transferred over in to New Spain creating
what we now call the Mexican Inquisition.
The Mexican inquisition was focused heavily
on converting the larger native population
in to Catholicism.
The amerindians prior to the spanish arrival
had religion at the center of their society
and with their conversion to Catholicism this
did not change.
Even though in many areas this conversation
was forceful, ones converted the native population
became devout catholics that brought in many
aspects from their old religions.
There’s no better example of this then the
apparition of the Virgin Mary to an Indios
farmer in the 16th century, now known as our
Lady of Guadeloupe.
The lady of Guadeloupe would later become
a symbol for the mestizo and amerindian parts
of the revolution.
This new found avid devotion to catholicism
by the native population combined with the
already existing avid devotion to catholicism
of the spanish, meant that the Catholic church
had almost just the same amount of power in
New Spain as the Spanish monarchy itself.
These three pillars of New Spain; governance,
religion and the casta system where the major
forces behind the way the Mexican war of independence
started and finished.
It all began during the Burbon reforms of
the 18th century when the new Burbon dynasty
in Spain hoped to reform their overseas territories
to bring new prosperity to their country.
These reforms were focused on centralizing
the administration of the colonies, reaffirming
more direct Spanish control over the colonies
and diminishing the power of the church.
However what the reforms ended up doing was
giving even more power to the Peninsulares
making the Criollos and Mestizos unhappy and
also making enemies with the church which
would later on make it more sympathetic towards
the mexicans during their strive for independence.
As animosity against spain grew in all the
social classes except the Peninsulare, the
ideas of a revolution became more and more
prominent within the mexican people.
All it needed now was a spark to light the
fire, and this spark came in a form of an
averagely tall Frenchman called Napoleon.
Napoleon’s peninsular war which started
in 1807 was very messy and after the 1808
forced abdication of the Spanish monarch,
destroyed any Spanish control in the new world.
Almost immediately after the abdication multiple
Juntas where created throughout spain, each
claiming to be the legitimate representation
of the Spanish government and its king.
These Juntas then sent out representatives
to the Spanish colonies, asking to be officially
recognized by them.
After receiving two representatives from two
different Spanish Juntas, the current Viceroy
of New Spain José de Iturrigaray, was very
confused.
Nonetheless this arrival of multiple representative
proved to everyone that Spain had no real
control over New Spain anymore, and so the
debate about what to do next started.
The Criollo party, which controlled the Mexico
City council, voted for self governance with
the current viceroy at its head.
Iturrigaray agreed as he was mostly a criollo
sympathizer and also would get to rule New
Spain.
However the Peninsulares who controlled the
audiencias vetoed this idea, arguing that
New Spain was a colony and therefor did not
have the right to self govern without Spain.
The peninsulares started to fear that their
control of New Spain was fading in favor of
the Criollos and therefor created a coup against
Iturrigaray, arresting him on some dubious
charges and quickly appointing one of their
own as a new Viceroy.
For the next year Pedro de Garibay acted as
the Viceroy of the colony for all intensive
purposes as if nothing was happening in Spain.
After a year he recognized the Spanish Junta
of Aranjuez whom mostly managed centralize
their power within Spain, and then he decided
to retire as he may have thought things bigger
than him where brewing across the colony.
He appointed Francisco Javier as his successor
but this guy also lasted only a year after
being replaced by the Junta of Aranjuez.
The new Viceroy Francisco Javier Venegas was
sent from Spain to quel now the extremely
unhappy population of New Spain.
This is because ever since the coup by the
Peninsulares against Iturrigaray most Mexicans
felt like they were forcefully controlled
by the unlawful government in mexico city
which seldomly cared for the people of New
Spain.
And this idea was the battle cry for the first
Mexican independence movement that started
just 2 days after Venegas took office.
Miguel Hidalgo y Costilla was the leader of
this movement starting in the town of Dolores.
The revolutionary army was small at first
numbering only around 600 men but the next
few days they traveled across the Mexican
countryside killing any Peninsulares they
came across and gaining much needed support,
equipment and manpower.
They also adopted the standard of the Virgin
of Guadalupe which would draw in much needed
Mestizo and Indios support for the revolution.
By the time the Viceroy was able to muster
up some sort of an army for defence Hidalgo
had around 100,000 men at his disposal.
Hidalgo met the much smaller New Spain's army
at the battle of Monte de las Cruces where
they scored a decisive victory.
Now with the Mexico city within their sight
Hidalgo made a decision that has puzzled historian
to this day.
He decided not to besiege Mexico city and
instead marched north towards the second most
important city in Mexico, Guadalajara.
Many of his troops disagreed with this choice
and started to deseret in mass.
Ones he arrived to Guadalajara his army numbered
only around 6000 men.
None the less he manage to take the city and
gained support from the cities lower classes
and the surrounding countryside.
By the time the new Viceroyal army arrived
to Guadalajara Hidalgo had again around 80
to 100 thousand men.
However the army was ill equipped and therefore
was decisively defeated at the battle of Calderon
Bridge.
After this defeat the revolutionaries tried
to flee towards the US but were later captured
and executed along with Hidalgo and with that
the Hidalgo’s independence movement was
over.
However the revolution itself was far from
The Peninsular abuse along with Hidalgos show
that the Spanish Could be defeated, meant
that many new insurgencies spurred up all
around New Spain.
Ignacio López Rayón in the center of the
country Father José María Morelos in the
south and various other groups all around
the Colony.
But all these groups weren’t united in their
pursuit for freedom.
Some wanted the status quo unchanged other
then having Mexico not be under spanish control
anymore and others wanted a full change of
the Mexican hierarchy, administrative system,
policies and religion.
Therefore it is unsurprising that due to such
disunity and difference of ideas the Mexican
revolution continued in a stalemate until
1820 but what actually happened then?
Well in 1820 after a decade of fighting the
various Mexican insurgencies where on the
brink of collapse, mostly due to the now apathetic
stans of the Mexican people which were sick
of fighting at this point.
But in comes Agustín Cosme Damián de Iturbide
y Arámburu a Mexican nobleman who in 1820
was a royalist a colonel and a General of
South of New Spain.
However despite his current status Iturbide
was a complicated man.
He was always a conservative sympathetic to
the royalists but he was also a criollo meaning
that throughout his life and military carrier
he faced setbacks due to the New Spain’s
casta system.
He was also asked by Hidalgo in the first
wave of the revolution to be a commander in
his army.
Iturbide however declined later joining the
royalists and fighting many of the insurgencies
of the 1810s.
From the victories he gained during this time
Iturbide garnered much prestige and support
of the more conservative Mexicans.
But by 1820 even Iturbide started to be fed
up with the entire war and the Peninsular
control of the government.
Plus being a conservative and a royalist when
Iturbide learned of a successful liberal revolution
in Spain which established a constitutional
monarchy, he just as many other conservative
Mexicans was afraid of what liberal changes
that would bring to a Monarchy centric New
Spain.
So when Iturbide was sent on what was suppose
to be the last royalist campaign against the
wavering revolutionaries, instead of fighting
them he attended a meeting with the insurgency
leader Vicente Guerrero.
It was even at this first meeting that signs
of problems started to appear.
Iturbide representing the Mexican conservative
values wanted a Monarchy with the aristocracy
on top, an independent Mexican Monarchy but
a monarchy nonetheless.
The revolutionaries on the other hand where
mostly republicans, hoping to establish a
USA like republic.
This divide was eventually settled by the
three guarantees.
First the newly independent Mexico will become
a monarchy under a Spanish or any other European
monarch that is willing to take the throne
but it will be a constitutional monarchy decided
upon to appease the liberals.
Second the aristocracy would still exist under
the Mexican Monarchy but the casta system
would be abolished, with all Mexican people
counted as equals.
Lastly to appease the conservatives and the
church the Catholic religion would become
the official and only religion of the new
Mexican Empire.
With this agreement which guaranteed the status
qou to be mostly unchanged for the higher
class and equality with representation in
the constitutional monarchy for the lower
class, for the first time in the Mexican revolution
most of the people were behind the same cause.
So the revolutionary armies and the royalist
armies under Iturbide combined forming the
army of the three Guarantees.
This army then marched towards mexico city
where it was greeted by a joyce papules shouting
Viva Iturbide!
Seeing the videranging support for the three
guarantees the Viceroy along with the few
remaining people still loyal to Spain escaped
and with that the Empire of Mexico was proclaimed
in 1821.
Iturbide managed to achieve what 11 years
of senseless fighting didn’t.
By compromising he manage to bring together
two main opposing factions and oust the Spanish.
He was hailed all around Mexico and was given
the leadership role of the regency while a
suitable Spanish or European nobel was searched
for.
However no European noble wanted to take the
spot of Emperor of Mexico.
(wait what why sounds like a great job, I
would take it) Well this was because back
in Spain the victorious liberals manage to
become the defeated liberals with the Spanish
Monarch regaining control.
He then set out to campaign against any other
European nobled taking the Mexican throne
and even had plans of invading Mexico himself.
The Mexican regency had no choice but to appoint
a Mexican noble on the throne.
And no Mexican noble was as famous or as well
regarded as Iturbide, so in 1822 allegedly
against his wishes iturbide was crowned as
Emperor Agustín I of Mexico.
Iturbide however was facing problems right
from the get go.
For example the conservative leaning areas
in Mexico still abided by the now technically
abolished casta system and the proclaimed
equality of the three guarantees wasn’t
really much existent.
Iturbide tried doing something against this
but that only lost him support with the hardline
conservatives which wanted the casta system,
on top of that he also lost support with the
royalists as they wanted a normal monarchy
not a constitutional one and also wanted a
european Monarch not a Mexican one.
On the other side of the political spectrum
Iturbide was hated by the republicans for
well existing as they wanted a republic not
monarchy.
Plus they thought he wasn’t doing enough
to enforce the abolishment of the casta system.
To add to all these problems Iturbide even
though a skilled general proved not to be
a skilled administrator or a politician.
Due to all this just a year later in 1823
the Republicans managed to gain control and
the sad and dimorelized Iturbide abdicated
after which he was exiled by the republicans.
When Iturbide was leaving the country it was
still very clear that even though the far
right and far left hated him he was still
loved by the majority of the country.
People gathered around his coach as he was
leaving and even insisted on pushing it themselves
instead of the horses.
When he came to the coast he left for Italy.
During his exile the situation in Mexico worsen.
The conservatives and royalists where in an
uproar as the republicans were in control.
The republicans themselves were divided unable
to create a cohesive governmental body that
would succeed the Empire and the southern
states of Mexico proclaimed independence creating
the united provinces of central america.
On top of all this the lower classes and the
far right liberals which up until now where
mostly controlled by the higher classes which
where mostly wealthy conservative Peninsulares,
started to actively barade and attack them.
This meant that many wealthy Peninsulares
and even some Criollos started to leave for
europe taking their wealth with them.
This wealth drain would continue for most
of the 19th century and arguably Mexico would
never recover from it.
In all this chaos the royalists convince Iturbide
to return to Mexico and restore order.
He did in 1824 but the wavering royalist party
along with many of the people that would support
him now leaving to Europe meant that he wasn’t
able to garner much political support and
power.
None the less he was still loved by the majority
of the people and the republicans basically
in a panic fearing an Iturbide takeover ordered
his execution.
Iturbide probably sick of fighting and not
wanting to cause another war which could destroy
Mexico even more, surrendered peacefully.
Many people called him incompetent, corrupt,
dictatorial, etc. and even though those words
usually where well founded, he always tried
putting Mexico first, for better or for worse.
His last words before a firing squad where,
"Mexicans!
In the very act of my death, I recommend to
you the love to the fatherland, and the observance
to our religion, for it shall lead you to
glory.
I die having come here to help you, and I
die merrily, for I die amongst you.
I die with honor, not as a traitor; I do not
leave this stain on my children and my legacy.
I am not a traitor, no."
Even after his death he was admired and respected
by most Mexicans and his life and demise represented
perfectly the dichotomy of Mexican politics
for the next 100 years.
With Mexico and its people going back and
forth between dictators and monarchs and republics.
That is where I will end this video as it
is already very long, I hope you enjoyed it
and I hope you’re enjoying the whole Project
Revolution it was a blast to make and work
with all these history youtubers.
If you want to continue to the next video
in colab let me point you towards House of
History video about the Boxer Rebellion
And the video prior to mine in the colab is
by Useful Charts about the monarchies involved
in the French Revolution.
My name is M.Laser and If you liked my video
subscribe and stick around for history.